26 de febrero de 1979
La Reina Isabel II inaugura oficialmente el
primer rascacielos de Dubai. Se trata de la
Sheikh Rashid Tower, más tarde conocida como
el World Trade Center de Dubai.
Queridos amigos, en su momento, fue la torre
más alta de todo Oriente Medio. ¿Lo sorprendente?
Qué fue levantada en medio del desierto,
en un lugar donde, como podéis ver, no había
gran cosa. Así que la operación no parecía
tener mucho sentido.
Sin embargo, fue toda una declaración de
intenciones. Con 39 plantas y 184 metros de
altura, este rascacielos dejaba claras las
intenciones del nuevo Dubái que estaba comenzando
a nacer: convertirse en un centro clave para
los negocios en Oriente Medio. Ese era el
objetivo.
Hoy, 5 décadas después, ese sueño se ha
hecho realidad.
Dubái se ha convertido en uno de los mayores
ejemplos de transformación, desarrollo y
éxito económico de toda la historia.
Y no, no son solo palabras. Actualmente, en
esta ciudad-emirato encontramos el edificio
más alto del mundo, el mayor centro comercial
del planeta, algunos de los hoteles más lujosos,
uno de los mayores aeropuertos internacionales,
un megapuerto de escala mundial y casi 400
rascacielos. Eso quiere decir que desde que
se inauguró el World Trade Center de Dubai,
esta ciudad ha con struido cerca de 10 rascacielos
nuevos cada año.
Y eso no es todo. Dubai también es la ciudad
del mundo, la número 1, con más super-rascacielos,
esto es, torres de más de 300 metros de altura.
Ninguna otra se acerca. Y sobre todo se ha
convertido en un auténtico imán para atraer
turistas, empresas y negocios de todas las
partes del mundo.
Y, amigos, si la historia de Dubái es resplandeciente…
La de Singapur no se queda atrás.
Esta ciudad-Estado es una de las metrópolis
más ricas, prósperas y exitosas de todo
el mundo. En las últimas 6 décadas y pese
a tener menos de 6 millones de habitantes,
ha pasado de ser una pobre plaza a convertirse
en un importante centro financiero, industrial
y comercial.
Gracias a ello, Singapur se ha convertidor
en uno de los países más ricos y desarrollados
de todo el mundo. En términos de PIB per
cápita, y exceptuando a los microestados,
el FMI lo sitúa como el cuarto país más
rico de todo el planeta. Hablamos de un PIB
per cápita esperado para 2023 de más de
90 mil dólares.
Y, ojo, porque esta ciudad, pese a su diminuto
tamaño, tiene, incluso, una de las fuerzas
armadas mejor dotadas de todo el planeta.
Por ejemplo, Singapur tiene más aviones de
combate que las fuerzas aéreas de países
como Canadá, Suecia o Países Bajos. ¡De
locos!
Lo miremos por dónde lo miremos, los números
de estas dos metrópolis son increíbles.
Y de hecho, la Red de Investigación sobre
Globalización y Ciudades del Mundo las sitúa
ni más ni menos que como dos de las nueve
ciudades más influyentes y económicamente
significativas de todo el mundo. Solo están
un paso por detrás de Nueva York y Londres,
las dos grandes capitales mundiales.
Fijaos.
Y precisamente por eso, aquí en VisualPolitik
ya os hemos contado en varios vídeos cómo
Dubai y Singapur consiguieron despegar y convertirse
en auténticos cohetes económicos, comerciales
y financieros. Básicamente, hablamos de dos
ciudades que se convirtieron en una especie
de ciudad-empresa.
De hecho, no es casual que los aeropuertos
de estas dos ciudades se sitúen entre los
más transitados de todo el mundo. Por ejemplo,
en 2019, el último año previo a la pandemia,
el aeropuerto de Dubai movió a 97,3 millones
de pasajeros y el de Singapur a 68,3 millones.
Ya veréis que no es algo casual.
Y de hecho, en esta línea, nos faltó prestar
más atención a uno de los elementos claves
de todo este proceso: la conversión de los
gobiernos de estas dos ciudades en auténticos
emprendedores.
Y la pregunta es,
¿Hasta qué punto fue importante el emprendimiento
público en el crecimiento y el desarrollo
de estos dos grandes polos económicos? ¿De
qué estamos hablando exactamente cuando decimos
que los gobiernos de estas ciudades fueron
auténticos emprendedores? ¿Se puede exportar
el modelo que tanto éxito ha tenido en Dubai
y Singapur a otros lugares más pobres?
Queridos amigos, amigas, en este segundo vídeo
de la serie que estamos preparando en colaboración
con Harvard International Review os respondemos
a todas estas preguntas. Os dejamos más información
en los links de la descripción.
Así que sin más preámbulo arranquemos.
T1 (COLUMNAS EN LA ARENA: DEL DESIERTO AL
MUNDO)
En 1997, Mohamed Alabbar, exDirector General
de Desarrollo Económico de Dubai, recibió
un encargo: fundar Emaar properties, hoy una
de las marcas más vistas y reconocidas de
todo Dubái. Su nombre está por todas partes.
No es extraño, es la promotora que ha llevado
a cabo los mayores proyectos de la ciudad:
el desarrollo del Downtown, del Burj Khalifa,
del Dubai Mall, de Dubai Marina o de muchos
de los hoteles de lujo. Hablamos de una empresa
ha desarrollado la mayor parte de las obras
que han dado forma al actual Dubai.
Prácticamente, todo lo que es característico
en esta ciudad ha sido promovido por Emaar.
Pero, ¿quién está detrás de esta promotora?
Pues bien, descubrámoslo.
Muy buenas, Alberto, el encargo de poner en
marcha esta compañía, esta promotora, fue
del propio gobierno del emirato dubaití.
El mismo gobierno que en el año 2000 la sacó
a cotizar en la bolsa local y que hoy sigue
controlando casi el 30% de una empresa que
con el paso de los años se ha convertido
en toda una multinacional. Hoy Emaar tiene
actividades en un montón de países diferentes,
gracias a lo cual en 2022 tuvo un beneficio
neto de casi 7.000 millones de dólares. Pero,
por supuesto, la joya de la corona de esta
compañía sigue siendo Dubai, una ciudad
dónde los proyectos nunca se terminan. Uno
de sus últimos grandes proyectos está siendo,
precisamente, el desarrollo de Dubai Creek
Harbour, un nuevo y enorme distrito que en
los próximos años se convertirá seguro
en una de las grandes atracciones de esta
ciudad.
Por cierto, la mayor parte de la participación
del gobierno se canaliza a través de ICB,
la Investment Corporation of Dubai, el músculo
de inversiones del gobierno dubaití que además
de Emaar controla o tiene inversiones en otras
muchísimas compañías.
Gracias, Enrique. De hecho. La Investment
Corporation of Dubai ha tenido mucho que ver
con el éxito de esta ciudad.
Este brazo de inversión del gobierno controla
activos por valor de más de 300 mil millones
de dólares. Posee o tiene participaciones
en muchas de las principales empresas locales
como el banco Emirates NBD , el Dubai Islamic
Bank, las compañías aéreas, Emirates o
flyDubai y la promotora Emaar de la que ya
os hemos hablado antes, entre más de 60 empresas
participadas total o parcialmente. ¿Y de
dónde procede el dinero que invierten? Pues
básicamente de emitir deuda, de reinvertir
los beneficios y los superávits de las cuentas
públicas.
Pero lo más interesante es que a lo largo
de los años el gobierno de Dubái ha utilizado
esta sociedad para promover negocios en la
ciudad o cubrir aquellas áreas que importantes
para el desarrollo general. Pero eso sí,
lo hizo siguiendo una estricta política de
mercado. Las empresas participadas o promovidas
tenían y tienen que ser competitivas no solo
en Dubai, sino que tienen que lograr ser capaces
de competir en el mercado internacional. Esto
generaría beneficios suficientes como para
que este vehículo pueda seguir invirtiendo
en nuevos proyectos.
Un buen ejemplo es el caso de Emirates.
Es evidente que en 1979, cuando se inauguró
el World Trade Center de Dubai, esta ciudad
tenía un problema: estaba aislada del mundo.
¿Quién querría hacer un largo viaje para
llegar a un sitio tan inhóspito? Sin embargo,
si quieres convertirte en un centro financiero,
turístico y comercial, necesitas una cosa:
comunicaciones.
Pues bien, para solucionarlo, en marzo de
1985 el emirato de Dubai creó Emirates, una
aerolínea que revolucionaría el transporte
aéreo intercontinental y que lograría hacer
de esta c iudad-emirato uno de los enclaves
mejor conectados de todo el planeta.
No importa si quieres volar a Tokio, a Sídney
o a Londres. En Dubai, siempre tienes conexiones.
Para lograrlo, a comienzos de 1985 el gobierno
de Dubai le dio al empresario británico Maurice
Flanagan 10 millones de dólares y todas las
facilidades administrativas que fueran posible.
¿Su objetivo? Lanzar en 5 meses una aerolínea
que tenía que funcionar bien y ganar dinero.
No habría subsidios ni protección extra.
La empresa tenía que volar, nunca mejor dicho,
por sí misma.
Y vaya si lo hizo.
Hoy Emirates es una de las aerolíneas más
grandes y rentables de todo el mundo. Tiene
actividad en 148 aeropuertos de todo el mundo
y en 2022, pese a que el sector todavía arrastra
los efectos de la pandemia, ganó casi 3.000
millones de dólares.
Pero, sobre todo, Emirates consiguió que
Dubai sea uno de los enclaves mejor conectados
del mundo. Lo que ha facilitado que lleguen
a esta ciudad trabajadores, empresarios, inversores
y, por supuesto, también, turistas. Fijaos.
(7 agosto de 2023: Dubai recibe más de 8,55
millones de visitantes en 6 meses, superando
los niveles anteriores a la pandemia Arabian
Business)
El caso es que junto a las zonas económicas
especiales, los bajos impuestos y la seguridad
jurídica, el éxito de Dubai tiene otro ingrediente
clave: el espíritu emprendedor de su gobierno.
Pero emprendedor, no para crear ineficientes
y elefantiásicas empresas públicas, sino
para impulsar la creación de empresas que
al tiempo que promueven la economía local
tienen que ganar dinero y ser muy competitivas,
cueste lo que cueste.
Pero, eso ni siquiera es todo. La idea del
Estado emprendedor va mucho más allá. En
Dubai, la inmensa mayor parte de los proyectos
públicos solo salen adelante si tienen visos
de ser rentables. Y el gobierno también apoya
a las empresas privadas. Por ejemplo, una
de sus últimas iniciativas ha sido lanzar
un fondo de casi 300 millones de dólares
para promover que 1.000 empresas tecnológicas
nuevas se instalen en Dubai.)
En fin, ya lo veis, casi que podríamos decir
que este emirato-ciudad funciona más como
una empresa que como un gobierno convencional.
Y desde luego hoy por hoy su éxito es innegable.
Claro que no es un caso único.
El éxito de Singapur tiene también mucho
que ver con todo esto. Atentos.
T2 (LA CIUDAD DEL MERLION)
En 1942 los japoneses se hicieron con el control
del enclave británico de Singapur.. Una ciudad
estratégicamente situada, que el imperio
británico había convertido en una importante
ba se naval y que sufrió mucho durante la
segunda guerra mundial.
Al final de la misma, la ciudad era un desastre:
los daños sufridos eran enormes, muchas infraestructuras
si no la mayoría estaban destruidas y las
tasas de mortalidad, violencia y corrupción
eran altísimas.
Singapur era una ciudad muy pobre en la que
prácticamente nadie en su sano juicio querría
vivir. Y, ¿sabéis qué? El futuro no pintaba
mucho mejor.
Luego, la guerra de Corea y la demanda mundial
de estaño y caucho lograron que las cosas
mejoraran y Singapur recobrara su papel como
puerto comercial. Pero poco más. Incluso
existía la amenaza de que la ciudad sufriera
una revolución comunista.
En 1958 la ciudad logró su total autonomía,
y en 1963, tras declarar su independencia
definitiva del Imperio Británico, se integró
en Malasia. Sin embargo, la cosa no funcionó.
En el 65 la federación malaya echó a Singapur.
Comenzaría así su camino en solitario…
Lo cual, no permitía ser particularmente
optimistas. Singapur era básicamente una
isla pobre y sin recursos naturales. Ni siquiera
tenía suficiente agua potable para dar de
beber a su población. El agua tenía que
importarse de Malasia.
Por supuesto, hoy las cosas son totalmente
diferentes. Durante los siguientes 60 años,
Singapur experimentó un boom sin precedentes
que lo ha llevado a convertirse en el cuarto
país más rico de todo el mundo. Un lugar
tremendamente próspero y con uno de los niveles
de vida más altos de todo el planeta.
Por supuesto, como ya os hemos contado en
VisualPolitik la apertura a la inversión
extranjera, un alto nivel de seguridad jurídica,
impuestos relativamente bajos y una clara
vocación por el ahorro fueron elementos clave.
Sin embargo, el éxito de Singapur también
ha tenido otro ingrediente,
Al igual que hemos visto con el caso de Dubai,
el gobierno de Singapur también tuvo una
clara vocación emprendedora… ¿Enrique?.
En 1974 el gobierno de Singapur fundó TEMASEK,
una especie de fondo soberano o brazo de inversión
que hoy gestiona activos por valor de casi
300 mil millones de dólares americanos. Lo
que supone más de 50 mil dólares por ciudadano.
Lo más curioso de todas formas es que el
gobierno de Singapur creó este vehículo
financiero para aglutinar las empresas públicas
y alejar de ellas a los políticos y a los
funcionarios. La idea es que las 35 empresas
pertenecientes o participadas por el Estado
en aquel momento funcionaran como auténticas
empresas privadas, incluso aunque siguieran
perteneciendo al estado.
Ese fue el comienzo, pero luego con los beneficios
reinvertidos empezaron a invertir en nuevas
empresas para impulsar su crecimiento. Hasta
el año 2002 TEMASEK concentró la inmensa
mayor parte de sus inversiones en Singapur,
pero luego comenzaron a invertir en el resto
del mundo, sobre todo en Asia. La idea es
que esas inversiones en empresas extranjeras
crearan o fortalecieran los lazos de empresas
con la propia Singapur. Por ejemplo, casi
una cuarta parte de todas sus inversiones
están en China.
Al final, con el paso de los años, TEMASEK
no solo permitió profesionalizar las empresas
públicas, sino que también se ha convertido
en una enorme hucha para el gobierno y ha
contribuido a impulsar un montón de nuevas
empresas. Sobre todo en sectores considerados
estratégicos para la ciudad.
¿Os acordáis de lo que antes hablábamos
de Emirates? Pues en Singapur ocurrió algo
similar. TEMASEK es el mayor accionista de
Singapore Airlines, tiene el 55% de las acciones.
Con su ayuda, esta aerolínea no solo conectó
a Singapur con el resto del mundo, sino que
también se convirtió en una de aerolíneas
más reputadas. Y lo que, por supuesto, es
aún mejor, también en una de las más valiosas
y rentables compañías aéreas de todo el
planeta. El beneficio estimado para 2023 se
acerca a los 2.000 millones de dólares americanos.
Y lo mismo podríamos decir de otras muchas
compañías.
Queridos amigos, con este tipo de estrategias,
tanto Dubai como Singapur lograron varios
objetivos:
Primero, cubrieron algunas carencias importantes,
como las comunicaciones.
Segundo, contribuyeron a profesionalizar las
empr esas públicas.
C1("Una de las trágicas ilusiones que tienen
muchos países del Tercer Mundo es la noción
de que los políticos y los funcionarios públicos
pueden desempeñar con éxito funciones empresariales.
Es curioso que, ante la abrumadora evidencia
de lo contrario, la creencia persista". Dr.
Goh Keng Swee, Ex-Ministro de Finanzas de
Singapur)
Tercero, ayudaron a impulsar y desarrollar
un montón de sectores económicos, lo que
a su vez atrajo a un montón de empresas y
profesionales extranjeros. Es decir, por sí
mismas, estos brazos de inversión han impulsado
muchísimo - y aún lo hacen - la inversión
extranjera.
Y cuarto han creado una hucha enorme que genera
miles de millones de dólares de beneficios
cada año.
Y no olvidéis que estamos hablando de dos
territorios relativamente pequeños. Dubai
tiene una población, incluyendo a todos los
profesionales extranjeros, de apenas unos
3 millones y medio de persoanas. Singapur,
por su parte, unos 5 millones y medio. Y pese
a ello, las cantidades que estamos analizando
son formidables.
Por supuesto, además de crear estos brazos
de inversión, ambos gobiernos abrieron sus
puertas de par en par a las empresas extranjeras
y promovieron la actividad empresarial como
si no hubiera mañana.
Entonces, la pregunta que podemos hacernos
es, ¿Se podría replicar este mismo modelo
para ayudar a desarrollar regiones mucho más
pobres? ¿Sería posible crear ciudades parecidas
en lugares de África o, incluso, América
Latina?
Y, ojo, que no es tontería. Por ejemplo,
la falta de seguridad jurídica, apertura
y conectividad hacen que Miami sea la sede
para las actividades en América Latina de
más de 1.400 multinacionales. Si en Latinoamerica
encontráramos un espacio tan amigable para
los negocios como Dubai o Singapur, es muy
posible que la inmensa mayor parte de esas
multinacionales no estarían en Miami, sino
en esa otra ciudad.
Por otra parte, mientras que Dubai y Singapur
han construido enormes huchas que además
han promovido el desarrollo económico, los
países latinoamericanos exportadores de materias
primas no han tenido tanta suerte. Por supuesto,
Venezuela es un ejemplo de libro. Hablamos
de decenas y decenas de miles de millones
de dólares que en lugar de contribuir al
desarrollo nacional fueron dilapidados.
Pero sea como sea, llegados hasta aquí la
pregunta ahora es para ti: ¿Qué te parece
el modelo de gobierno emprendedor de Dubai
y Singapur? ¿Crees que fórmulas así serían
replicables en América Latina o en África?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios.
Espero que este nuevo entre VisualPolitik
y Harvard International Review os haya resultado
tan interesante como a nosotros. Si es así,
no olvidéis darle a like y suscribiros al
canal si es que aún no lo habéis hecho.
Muchas gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.